[Music]
caps entitled self-righteous freeloaders
going around sucking the souls from
sleeping
babies you feed a cat he always looks at
you like you're an hour
late it's about time could you mix the
dry with the
wet you feed a dog dog's so grateful he
all but says a human thank you he tries
Tok I love
you I need you
[Music]
Phil just saying give me a dog loyalty
personality tricks they do tricks
humping humping things that's fun that's
a feature of a dog it'll really break up
that awkward family dinner Uncle Dave's
rounding the 20th minute of his
anti-china
tirade cat will leave you hanging cat
will just watch laughing letting you
ridee in the tension a dog a dog will
help out he'll come in and straight up
the
couch thank you dog that shut Dave
up yeah just have a strong
sorry what do I have to do everything
perfect you can't give me a little roll
you just go right to
zero 80% of you were holding your
breath he can't even hear my breath show
him what a loone is you
dummies I'm just saying have a strong
opinion on anything anything day person
or night person night night the day
listen the day birds chirping hey Birds
quitting with all that chirping you
chirp Monsters the Sun up there on his
throne judging me it's too early to
drink Pete
you you son Bella the key to a better
life you're
[Music]
welcome